(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are exploring the question
what are our greatest physical feats?
And I don't mean like which
of our feet are bigger,
but my left foot is a little bit bigger
than my right foot, in
fact, a half size bigger
than my right foot.
- That seems like it could be a problem.
- Yes, my greatest physical
foot is my left foot.
(both chuckle)
It's like a size 12.2
and my right foot is like
a size 11.7.
- Eight.
Seven, okay.
- Mm-hmm, so I just get 12 and
call it even, call it a day.
- Now actually one of my feet is bigger
than the other foot too
because back when we,
along with the help of
all of the Mythical Beasts
at the time, we designed
a shoe that we then sold.
I don't know if you knew this,
called the Mythical Shoe,
and when you start to make your own shoe,
it was basically like,
it was a fabulous Converse
ripoff shoe, I mean.
- Whoa.
- It had a wing embroidered
on the side--
- 'Cause it was canvas
and had a--
- We threw a lot at that shoe.
It had a guitar pick holster.
- Yeah.
(Link laughs)
- And it--
- The Mythical Shoe,
I still love the idea.
- That was like a nice
tasteful black and white
but then there was also
like a oh my gosh, look
away blue and green.
- No that was the fun pair.
- Then we made all,
anyway, I digress, but
when you find yourself,
just a heads up, whenever
you find yourself making
your own branded shoe as you will,
you'll find that you have the
luxury of getting them to fit
exactly how you want and I found out
that one of my feet is bigger
than the other one too.
- Do you know which one?
- 'Cause I'm like,
oh I wanted a 10 and a half in one foot
and an 11 in the other one.
- But which one,
is it your left foot?
- I can't remember.
I can't remember 'cause once
I ran out of those shoes
I'm like, I gotta forget that happened.
I don't have that luxury anymore.
- Mine is noticeable
with any pair of shoes
that I try on, that's why I
always just try on the left shoe
at shoe stores.
- And then wear two socks
on the right--
- No it's not that big
of a difference, it's just
like if the left foot fits,
I know the right foot's gonna fit.
Also my left arm is
longer than my right arm,
probably by a quarter
to a third of an inch,
so much so that when I get
measured for like a fitted shirt,
they have to measure it differently.
- Really?
- My left, one of my eyes
is a little bit bigger
than the other, which one is it?
- The left one.
- The left one, yeah.
My whole left side of the body--
- I think that the eye opening is bigger.
The eyeball's probably the same--
- The eyeball's the same size.
Yeah, I think there's other things that,
but interestingly--
- You always look like
you're about to wink.
- All injuries--
- It's not that bad.
- All the injuries are on
the right side of my body.
My elbow, my wrist, my shoulder, my hip,
and my knee.
All right side, the weak side, man.
But I'm right-handed.
Isn't this weird?
- I don't know if it's weird.
- So we are gonna talk about
our greatest physical feats.
- Oh and did you happen to notice--
(metal jangling)
What, what, a little, what?
A little jingle around my neck?
- This is not how Olympic medalists,
if that's what you are.
You gotta learn to wear
the prizes in style, Link.
We continue to try to teach you this,
to win with some sort of decorum but--
- To win like I've expected it?
- Yes.
- Well, this is my--
- Act like you've been there
before as Josh Young told you
after you scored a goal one time.
- Two goals in one game.
- Yeah.
- I mean if you're not watching
the video version of this,
I'd be happy to fill
you in on the fact that
I am sporting around my
thick, muscular neck,
the weight--
- His 15 and a half inch neck.
(laughing)
- The weight of a hefty
physical feat completed
and that is, I ran in a Spartan Race.
And I got a medal.
I got a medal, I'm wearing it.
I got a Science Olympiad medal once.
- I will note that you
just turned it around
and it just said finisher
on it, so I mean--
- Yeah, I didn't get a place.
- But hey, you know what, you finished.
I didn't even do it.
- I finished.
You didn't even start.
- I didn't even start.
- Then on the back there's
a third of another medal
that if I complete apparently
two more Spartan Races
in this calendar year, I get
a big daddy trifecta medal.
- That's smart marketing, man.
- Yeah.
- Especially a collector,
you definitely wanna get the
other two pieces of that.
- Right I don't even know how
but I'm probably already signing up.
- So Link's gonna tell
us about his experience
with the Spartan Race
and then we're gonna talk
about some other physical feats but I do--
- And I will say that I discovered,
just a little more of a tease,
something happened that
I did not anticipate
that I think is gonna have a
forever impact on who I am.
- Okay.
My interest is piqued.
- Is it?
- Piqued with a Q.
- Okay.
- I'm going to answer some questions
that been lingering out there.
Those of you who follow my
very dynamic Instagram account,
RhettMC, also the same
name of my very dynamic
and awesome Twitter account, RhettMC.
Shout-out to both of those accounts.
I encourage you to follow
both of them for enrichment.
- Right and if you wanna complete the set,
let's just shout-out to
LinkLamont on Instagram.
- That's right.
- He's very active.
- Yeah yeah.
- Very active.
- Very, very active now.
- Like when the Amish go
and sow their wild oats,
that active.
- Whoa.
- You know how they have
a year they can do that?
- Better protect yourself.
- I don't know what they call it.
But it's where they can
sow their wild oats.
- I think that's what they call it.
I think they call it the devil's year.
- I'm that active on Instagram now.
- I posted this video to both accounts.
I thought it deserved
that kind of exposure.
- Yes, and I haven't gotten
the complete download.
Again I can't--
- You can't download--
- I've heard pieces--
- Instagram videos.
I've tried.
- You're talking about the cat.
- Yeah.
- Yes!
- You may have seen that I posted a video,
about a minute long video
of a night vision camera
focused on the couch in my living room
which is actually a cropped
version of the bigger video.
- [Link] Oh nice, you did some cropping.
- I wanted to draw your eye to the cat
and I said something like,
see this cat on my couch at 3 a.m.?
Here's the thing.
We don't have a cat.
♪ Dun dun dun ♪
- And I left it at that and apparently
that was incredibly strategic
because it was like my
most-liked post ever.
- How many likes?
- I think at the time
that we're recording this,
I think it's been seen
almost 300,000 times
on either or Instagram
or both, I don't know,
which is a lot for a video
on those platforms for me.
- I think I need to know an exact number
if I'm gonna compare it
to my return to Instagram.
- Okay.
- How many likes does that have, Alex?
- 287,000.
- Ooh!
- Gah!
I think you blew me out of the water!
(Rhett chuckles)
Okay but--
- That's views.
- That's views though.
- Oh that's view,
no, no, no likes.
- [Alex] 63,296 likes.
- Okay, ha.
- Yeah because people
don't usually like videos
as much as they just watch them.
- Okay yeah, that's a decent number.
It's not what I got when I, you know,
when I came back to Instagram.
- Well I think that the
real comparison should be
your watermelon outfit picture
to my watermelon outfit picture.
So let's--
- Oh.
Now something tells me--
- Let's bring those up.
- Something tells me you've done this
because I can see the glimmer in your eye.
- No no I just--
- Of course, I haven't done it.
I haven't done it.
- [Alex] Rhett, you have 117,085.
- 117,000 likes on Rhett's watermelon.
- [Alex] I mean you're
close Link, you have 107.
- Okay and by the time that this is--
- Oh it'll--
- You will have surpassed me.
- Oh yeah.
- By the time that this is--
- Blow it out.
- On the air, air waves.
- Yeah mine's still on the upward trend.
Okay but anyway, that's all you wrote
on your Instagram caption but--
- There was more to the
story as Paul Harvey,
is that his name, used to say.
Everybody loves Paul Harvey,
the rest of the story.
- Yeah he said the rest of the story,
not there's more to the story.
(Rhett chuckles)
- The real story is not as exciting
as Satan manifested himself
as a cat in my living room.
'Cause that's what I wanted you to think.
- Mm-kay.
- That did not happen
as far as I know.
What happened was, 'cause
I also don't make a habit
of just watching my, looking
at my couch all night long
through the (chuckles) video,
going back through the archives.
- Yeah how would you even find it?
- I woke up.
I walked downstairs as
I do when I wake up.
- Was this the middle of the night?
Or the morning?
- This was the morning.
And the front door was just wide open
and I knew that I was the
first person downstairs.
I knew I was the only person awake.
And so I was like okay,
that means that this door
has been opened all night.
I mean like open and come on in, friends.
- Agape.
- Yeah.
And so I did what we do in my house
when you encounter a problem,
I immediately tried to
figure out who to blame.
(Link chuckles)
And so I knew that Locke
had had friends over
the night before and so I
yelled upstairs, "Locke!
"Did your friends leave the door open?
"I think your friends left
the door open last night.
"It was open all night!"
And he yelled back, "No, Dad!"
- Healthy communication climate.
- That's how we communicate
in the McLaughlin household.
- Was he, was that point-blank range
and you just yell like that or--
- Yeah he was right next to me.
- Okay. (chuckles)
- He was upstairs.
And then I said, "Well I'm gonna check
"the video camera footage!"
- You didn't believe him.
- So I went into the
archives that I can access
via my phone and I started
to, 'cause basically,
if you zoom out that image of the couch
to the far left is the front door.
It's sort of the, it's the living room
and the front door
camera that gets it all.
- Okay yeah.
- And I, kinda scrubbing through
but I'm kinda scrubbing
through ham-handedly
so that I accidentally
scrubbed all the way to 3 a.m.
- Whoops.
- And then I see this little dot.
- Well, did you see the
door had been left open
or something?
- Well yeah okay so skipping forward
and then I'll come back, I did
see that it was his friends
who left and did not close the door.
(Link chuckles)
So it was his--
- Did you yell at him then?
Or you were distracted by--
- I was focused on the cat
at this point.
- Okay go ahead.
- But they walked out and
they pulled the door too
but it didn't close all the
way and then it was like
a windy night so it
just blew the door open.
- Okay.
- But what I saw was that little black dot
and then it took a lot,
it takes a lot to get back
to the specific little minute, you know.
- Right.
- Then I'm like--
- 'Cause this is like
an eight hour video.
- That's a frickin' cat.
A cat came in and at first I
thought, is that a raccoon,
and some people still think
that they see a raccoon in that.
It's very hard to tell and
there is a family of raccoons
that lives in the lot next to me.
Like literally a family,
one time I saw the mom,
she was walking across
the fence next to the pool
and three baby raccoons
were following her.
- That's cute.
- And also if you listen to the video,
you'll see that at the end
after the cat disappears
sort of behind the wall,
there's like a repeated sound
of like somebody taking like a cord
and hitting against the floor,
which that's a very raccoon thing to do.
(whacking)
Cats don't make that,
cats don't leave a mark.
They're like evil spirits that
just float through spaces.
They don't step heavy and stuff like that.
- So in the video you posted--
- But I do think it was a cat.
- The cat jumps off the
couch behind the couch?
- No no it comes to the edge of the couch
which is behind the
wall, kind of the corner
of the room where there's
that light and then like--
- The camera view was obstructed.
Oh.
- And he did something.
I don't know what it was,
but I'm 90% sure it was a cat
and it's a black cat that
I think is a neighbor's cat
that is kind of around
and we don't feed cats.
I don't believe in
feeding cats as a policy.
I believe that some cats should be fed.
I'm not saying that, I'm just
saying that I don't feed cats.
- You don't believe in you feeding cats.
- And it's a neighbor's cat
that's one of those roving cats.
- Yeah, if you feed it,
it'll keep coming back.
- And so apparently he
just thought it was okay
to come inside.
Apparently he didn't
understand the disposition
of our household towards cats.
- Because you didn't,
did you see the cat exit,
or if not, did you think the
cat may still be in the house?
- No I thought he had probably gone.
I thought he had left.
- At that point you were
thinking about an Instagram post.
- Oh yeah.
- You had moved on from Locke being wrong
and you being right and
from a cat being there
to how do I exploit this digitally?
- Yeah yeah and that was when my wife
and I had the conversation about,
'cause I think she was like,
well I should tweet that or something.
I'm like whoa, whoa, I should tweet that.
(both laugh)
- Oh really? (laughs)
You guys are trying to
out-tweet each other.
- No 'cause I'm like well, you know,
I think that my post
has the most potential.
- Ooh.
(Rhett laughs)
Did you give her the line,
you can retweet my tweet?
- No, she did.
She did come up with some of the verbage.
I think she came up
with, here's the thing,
we don't have a cat.
It was a collective tweet.
- She's your ghostwriter.
- Yeah she's my ghostwriter.
And so it's also like, just the other day,
it's funny because now
that she's on Twitter,
I mean she's got an Instagram
account that's private,
well she's got one that's
like her design thing
that's public and then
she's got one that's herself
that's private, but Twitter
of course is just public
for everybody, so she's kinda gettin'
into the fray a little bit on Twitter.
And so now when things happen at home,
there's a little bit of a race, like so,
my most-liked tweet
ever as of this weekend
was my, I was like, Jessie asked Shepherd,
she said, "What kind of eggs do you want?"
And he said, "Pancakes."
It's got like 20 something thousand likes.
'Cause I just tweeted, my
wife to my 10 year old:
what kind of eggs do you want?
10 year old: pancakes.
People just love that.
- You had no role in
that except tweeting it.
- Yeah right and so and
as soon as it happened,
I was like, that's a
good tweet and it's funny
because Jessie was actually,
she was part of the tweet
but she didn't, we recognized
it was funny at the time,
but she didn't immediately
think I gotta tweet that.
- Oh and so she lost.
- Yeah but she commented on it.
- It's an interesting thing
because, what was the comment?
Like, hey this should have been my tweet?
- No she says she made a joke about eggs
or pancakes, I can't remember exactly.
I liked it.
- She glommed on
and you liked it.
It's funny because I don't
tweet that much, you know,
we've talked about this.
I'm off of that now.
I'm onto the new thing, the
new thing called Instagram.
But Britton who now lives with us,
he started tweeting things
that are said around my house.
- Oh, so he's doing that.
- So he's doing what you're doing.
He's listening in to stuff
in the Neal household
and then tweet it, like
stuff that Christy's saying,
he's tweeting it.
- There's a treasure trove there.
- Yeah but of course I can't do that.
I can't be the one that's like,
here's something my wife said,
implying like you'll find this hilarious.
- I follow Britton on Twitter
but I haven't followed him closely enough
to see these tweets that you speak of.
- I don't follow him either.
No I do but--
- I do follow him.
But I'm just saying I don't,
I just look at moments
and mentions on Twitter
so I don't see a lot.
- He told me he did--
- That's another thing
my wife says, she's like, I walk home.
I walk in home. (chuckles)
And she says, "He didn't like my tweet."
- Oh.
- I'm like I didn't see your
freakin' tweet, I'm sorry.
I'll go like it now.
- Dang.
- Yeah yeah it's only if she thinks
that her tweet was deserving
of a like, and it often is.
But I haven't seen these Britton tweets.
So how many times has he
done this and does he say,
my, how does he characterize it?
- He's trying out this
catchphrase that's like,
he'll give the exchange, and
then he'll say something like,
another day in the Neal
household or something.
- #AnotherDayInTheNealHousehold.
- Yeah something like that.
- He gotta shorten that.
- You know.
I'm letting him do his
own experimentation.
Even though I am an expert in Twitter.
Who am I?
Who am I to give him
advice on the tweeting?
- Okay so that's the story,
it's not as exciting as,
I mean it's still a little bit exciting
but it was just as simple
as leaving the door open.
Fun fact, if you leave your door open,
animals and/or people, I
mean, I should be happy
that it was just a cat and
not a cat burglar. (chuckles)
- And that the cat left.
You could be taking
care of a cat right now.
- Well I wouldn't be, I
would have escorted it out.
- Okay.
All right we're gonna get
into my race and what happened
and how my life was
potentially changed or not.
But first, we wanna just encourage you
to buy some stuff from us.
I mean let's be real.
We're sellin' stuff, you can rep it.
Mythical.store.
- Why don't you grab
that hat there Link?
- Has hats.
- 'Cause I've got a hat in my hand.
I'm not gonna wear 'em
'cause who would do that?
Well Link's wearing his.
I have a tan hat.
- Works great over a set of cans.
Put it over your cans.
That's a euphemism for headphones.
- This is a way the kids
are wearing the hats now.
It's just lightly placed
on top of the head.
- Gingerly.
- Wow, look how big my
head looks when I do that.
(Link chuckles)
- Your head can look this big too.
Go to Mythical.store.
Get that and all types of other stuff.
- Bigger head, bigger brain.
- Okay Link, tell us
about your experience.
- Spoiler alert, I got a medal.
I don't know if I pointed that out earlier
but I got a, I mean it is a heavy medal.
Like hold your hand up.
There it is.
- Yeah makes you feel like
you did something.
- Substantial, man.
Reminds me of when we made medals
for our Supernote competition.
Arguably the largest YouTube
collaboration/competition
to date, to that date on YouTube.
- At least that's what we called it.
- At least that's what we said.
- That's how we marketed it.
True or not.
- It was a competition
to see who could hold out
the longest continuous
vocal note (chuckles)
on the internet.
We should bring that back.
- Oh gosh.
It was a nightmare.
- It's a different world now.
It's a different internet world.
Anyway, we made medals like this
but this one's pretty freakin' cool.
Oh you want this hat out,
which one, Rhett's fault.
So I go to a gym and
they're doing things like,
a lot of people at my gym,
they'll get on Facebook
and they'll talk to each
other and encourage each other
and there's a, and of
course, I don't do that.
- Encouragement.
Encouragement's for losers.
- I'm there for the burpees,
I'm there for the tonage.
I'm there to just get fit.
I mean the first thing
that got me into the gym
three years ago now, ish, was,
I was having shoulder problems,
I was having knee problems,
I went to physical therapy,
they taught me some exercises
that then made me feel
better but I was like,
I gotta maintain my body.
I gotta turn a corner here
so I started going to the gym
but I'm not one of these
people that's like,
I'm doing this for me, I'm
doing this for my health,
I'm doing it for my
wife and kids, you know,
to be physically a part of their lives.
You know? (chuckles)
- I think I know what you mean.
You said it differently than I would have.
(Link chuckles)
You wanna be around, you wanna be engaged,
you wanna be spry.
- Yeah I wanna be able
to grab 'em and toss 'em.
- You wanna be young at heart and in body.
- Yeah, man, and not get hurt.
Arm wrestle.
That kinda thing.
- Show 'em who's boss.
- But the social aspect of
it was not really my thing,
so I'm not really, I mean I know people,
I have friends at the gym but you know,
at the end of last year,
I'm thinking there's some things that,
I'm trying to be more open
to even more experience,
especially when it relates to self-care.
And I think those two
things coming together
led me very early on
at the top of the year,
as I was leaving the gym,
the guy just mentioned,
hey there's a sign up
for the Spartan Race.
And I'd heard of this and
some people had done it before
and a lot of people sign
up, they do it as a group
from the gym and I really
didn't think about it,
I was like, I'm gonna do that.
I looked at the date, I
knew we weren't out of town.
And I just signed up.
It was kinda like I was
observing myself make a decision
that I never thought I would make.
It was like an out-of-body experience.
And I was like I'm doing this.
I don't know why, I'm just,
I'm gonna give it a shot.
I'm open now, I'm more interested in,
I don't know what's involved in this race.
And then the next time I got to the gym,
I was like, maybe you
should tell me a little bit
about this thing that I'm gonna be doing,
this Spartan Race.
He was like, well we don't
train here, it's like,
you gotta come Sunday
mornings first thing.
We're gonna meet out at a park
and we're gonna do
special training for it.
I'm like okay.
You gotta run a 5K and
there's 20 obstacles
all along the way and
there's a Spartan Race,
there's a Tough Mudder,
there's all types of
things floating around
that I've heard about.
But I'm like okay I'm
gonna go to the training.
I'll see how this shapes up.
I didn't really look on the website.
I made up my mind, I didn't
wanna look at the obstacles
or really try to
understand what's happening
'cause I felt like I would get nervous.
So I'm just gonna go to the
training on that Sunday morning.
- But the obstacles that were gonna be,
they weren't gonna replicate
the obstacles in this park.
Not to an exact degree, right?
- No when we went to the park,
there was just a small group
of us, like six of us,
and the trainer guy, my
friend who owns the gym.
- Do the obstacles change each year?
- They change from
location to location, yeah.
- So you don't really know
what you're getting into,
that's part of it.
- Yeah but I didn't even
wanna know like generally.
I knew there was mud
involved and they talked
about crawling under barbed wire.
Like well okay.
And I get there and it's just a park.
There's no obstacles at
all, I mean, it's just,
there's a dog park over here
and then there's a regular park over here
and so we have to pair up
and just start running a lap
around this park, off,
there's no, just on the dirt.
And then whenever we
would come back around,
we'd get down and we'd
start crawling on the dirt
and he had some bags
and we'd carry some bags
or we'd do burpees.
But he was talking about,
now, you gotta get low
and this is how you do an army crawl.
Just imagine there's a barb wire over top,
I'm like dang, am I gonna
be bleeding at this thing?
- Well if you don't get low enough.
- I think at Tough
Mudder, Jenna was telling,
they'll like shock you and stuff.
There was none of that for the Spartan.
The Spartan Race is not--
- The Tough Mudder gets up to--
- It's not as crazy as that.
- They all have different
levels but the most,
the highest Tough Mudder,
it's like a Tough Mudder.
- Yeah.
So this, you don't get
shocked, but you do get dirty
and you get down in it.
So like I'm learning
how to do an army crawl
in the middle of this
park and that's not easy,
you gotta have good hip mobility
to stay low.
And I'm crawling around on my belly
and all of a sudden I hear somebody say,
"What are you guys up
to?" and then I said,
"Oh we're training for a Spartan Race,"
and then I'm crawling up to this guy
and he's like walking
his dog, heckling us,
and he's like, "You pay to
crawl around on your belly
"out here like that?"
And I'm like, I wanted to say
something very nasty to him.
I bit my tongue, I didn't say anything.
- He was just trying to make conversation.
- And then I'm like, his dog is crapping.
- You pay for your dog to crap like that?
That would have been a bad comeback.
- So here I am crawling, I'm crawling,
there's like dog crap obstacles.
- Oh, thank you, sir.
- (chuckles) It's like kinda humiliating.
I was kinda second-guessing my decision
and then we start running and I realize
I am horrible at running.
Like, I know how to move
my legs like a runner
but it's something about
the breathing part of it
that is extremely difficult for me.
I was out of breath,
man, I was struggling.
- I learned this when we ran the mile--
- Yes.
- In our old studio
in a very small circle, and I
thought that you were joking.
I thought that the trouble
that you were having
with it was a bit.
- I think I have asthma.
(Rhett snickers)
I mean I don't wanna make light of asthma,
I just can't breathe when I start running.
- I think it's a rhythm thing.
- Yeah, I mean I was
asking about it, like,
my trainer was like--
- You're not breathing deeply enough.
- Yeah you gotta, you know,
the breathe in through your nose,
breathe out through your mouth.
I remember back when we were
in little league baseball,
we'd have to run laps around there.
It was like breathe in through your nose,
breathe out through your
mouth and I'm just like--
(panting dramatically)
So we paired up because,
and there's a woman
who had a French accent
whose name was Blandine.
- Wha wha what?
- I've seen her around?
- She sounds like a graphic
novel star or something,
like Blandine.
- Blandine the French woman
became my workout partner
so I'm running at--
- That's the best name.
- Great person too.
- That I've ever heard.
- Great person.
- I might have a daughter
just so I can have a Blandine.
I'm gonna get my vasectomy reversed.
I'm gonna go to one of those specialists
that can put your sperm in
a certrifuge to make sure
that only the female sperm
or whatever you call it,
get in there.
I'm gonna have a girl so
I can name her Blandine.
You heard it right here.
- And you need to set
the spin cycle to French so
she comes out speaking French.
- Oh gosh.
That could probably be
done, it's 20, is it 19?
It's 2019.
- You know what?
I never ask her to speak to me in French.
- (chuckles) Well good.
- But she has an accent.
She's a very nice person.
Her and her husband own
these gyms for kids,
you know how when you take
your kid to this place
and there might be trampolines
and obstacles and crap.
So she was--
- Oh like a jump center?
- Yeah so she's athletic-minded,
and we start running
and I'm like oh she's setting the pace.
(chuckles)
- Blandine, gotta keep with Blandine.
- Very early I'm like, uh,
I'm not good at running.
I don't think I know how to breathe right.
And then a few, like three minutes later,
I couldn't talk anymore so it
was like I couldn't object,
I just had to really try
to run to keep up with her.
- She was your partner though
so it's just you and her.
- It's not that she was running fast,
it's just that she was
running at a decent pace
and I don't know how to do that.
- Right.
- From a breathing point.
- It could be in your legs too.
Maybe your legs aren't
moving the right way.
They have an inefficient
stroke they call it.
- I achieved fatigue pretty quickly
but I pushed through just like it says
on the back of my medal.
Push harder.
- Okay.
Almost like it says--
- I'm training, man.
- On the back of your medal.
(chuckles)
- And when you get really
fatigued, it's hard to run
and I found myself falling.
We're running on the dirt and--
- Falling behind or falling?
- Like falling on my face.
Like falling, she was
running a little bit ahead,
it was a little bit of a
decline, it was like dirt
and gravelish type scenario
and whenever she would hit a little dip
and then it would go down and
up, she'd get some momentum
so it'd be like woo-woop
and so she could get up the other side.
I wasn't great at that either and I fell,
if it weren't for my hands catching me,
I would have fallen flat on my face
and like my knees bleeding and
she's like, "Are you okay?"
I'm like, "I'm not good at running."
(Rhett chuckles)
And I get up, I'm running
the rest, and then,
so I had a war wound, so
I come back the next week
and I got a knee brace.
- A knee brace.
- Over my knee wound.
- Okay.
- 'Cause my knee was
also hurting after that.
On the inside and the outside.
And then I'm running the next
time and Blandine's not there
'cause she had to go to
France for the holidays.
- Yeah of course.
- So I'm running with Lewis.
- Quarterly trip to France.
- Lewis is even faster than Blandine,
I'm trying to keep up with them.
(breathing erratically)
Just like sucking air.
We're running up in the
woods, we're coming down
from the woods on a decline
and he's well ahead of me
so he's stopping to do our burpees
and as he turns around and
looks, I give him a show.
Like I splayed out and
just (exhales sharply)
fell again.
On my hands and my knees,
I'm just like tumbling down this hill.
All because I can't run, I'm that tired.
I get so tired that my
feet wouldn't lift off
of the dirt.
And he's like, uh.
You don't know what to say
in that instance to the guy.
It's like you're training with this guy
and he's like, "Uh, you okay, man?"
And I'm like, "Yeah, I
did this last week too."
- (chuckles) I did this with Blandine.
- So then the next week I show up,
I got a knee brace on both knees.
- You need like a full body suit.
You need like a Kevlar three-piece suit.
- I need to look like somebody
that you do motion capture--
- Well what you need is
you need a four-wheeler
just to ride and follow everyone. (laughs)
- I need to begin efficient.
- I got a helmet and I
got a combustible engine
that propels me.
- So I became, I developed this
reputation amongst the group
of being the guy who is
gonna bleed every time.
- The falling bleeder.
(Link chuckles)
- Needless to say, come race
day, I was pretty nervous.
- Right.
- That didn't affect my
sleep because you know,
whenever my head hits
the pillow, I get stupid.
I am a stupid sleeper.
So I'm blessed with that but
when I woke up I was like,
man I'm kinda nervous.
We had to drive out to Chino
or Chico or what, Chino.
- Yeah you gotta know
which one you're going to.
- A lot of people out there.
I'm like oh I get to see these obstacles
and everything and--
- There's probably a lot of
falling bleeders out there too.
- I had on both of my knee braces.
They gave us socks so we
could all look the same
so I got these tube socks on my shins
and got a headband.
I always wear a headband, by the way.
That's my signature.
- I've heard about this.
- Every time I work out, I gotta--
- There's always one in every gym.
- I'm that guy. (chuckles)
- The guy with the headband.
- So--
- I usually don't talk to him,
but I would talk to you.
- Blandine and I take off, the race starts
and I'm like okay, I can do this.
I caught a glimpse of
some of the obstacles.
There's a three-foot wall you gotta
hoist yourself over that.
But there's like a five-foot wall
that like I'm hoisting myself up, well,
I put my foot out, Blandine
jumps off of my thigh
and I boost her over.
- Right 'cause--
- There's a teamwork--
- Mentality, and the
rest of our team there,
they decided to go at a
slower pace, and you know--
- Whoa whoa, hold on.
You went Blandine pace?
- I went Blandine pace.
- The day of the race?
- You know, I been training some more.
- Hold on, but was this
discussed ahead of time?
- Yeah, yeah I was like
all right, don't leave me.
Please.
- Just you and her?
- Yeah.
And there's--
- So there's no obstacles
where you need, I've--
- No.
- I've read a little bit about it
and I've seen pictures
where you gotta have
like three people minimum
to get over these certain
things or something.
- Only if this is like your first race
and you need help over
things does your team
rally around you to help
you get over things.
But for us we just had each other
and a lot of people were
just kinda paired up.
And then there's like,
you're climbing a net wall
and when I get up to
the top, I'm like man,
this is, it hits me that like,
if I were to fall from this,
I could die.
I gotta really be careful
and I got more scared.
And then we're going
over all types of stuff
and then there's a mud hill.
I'd say it's probably a six-feet tall,
muddy hill and you climb this
thing and you get on the top
and you slide down into muddy water.
- Mm-hmm.
- It's like three feet deep
and you're trudging across that.
Another muddy hill, it's taller.
- Was it cold?
- Conditions were perfect.
I would say it was like
74 degrees in the air.
- 'Cause that would be, cold
would be the worst part.
- So I get up on the second
hill and we're sliding down,
I'm like man, this is fun.
All of a sudden I'm having fun.
I'm not as scared anymore.
And so I slide down in that mud pit.
- Are you like saying woo?
Did you have anything that
you say when you get over a--
- I didn't have like fun
exclamations like yeehaw
or anything like that.
I kept my redneck inner dialogue inside.
- What kinds of things did you say?
- I went down there and I'm like,
my face didn't get muddy
but my shoulders did
and I'm in up to my
armpits and I turn around
and this big football player dude
makes a huge splash and when I turn around
and look at him, he has gone under.
He's got mud all over his face.
And I look at him and I
say, "You look great."
And--
- You encouraged someone.
- I encouraged someone.
- But you also seemed
like kinda making fun
of him a little bit.
- And he looked at me and I
noticed that he was struggling.
He's like wiping his
eyes with his muddy hands
and he was like, I got it in my eyes.
So he thought I was taunting him.
'Cause he was like having a moment.
- Yeah well that--
- I was like you look great.
- He was like, I got
it all in my eyes, man,
and he was upset.
And I was like oh--
- You sounded like you were
kinda making fun of him,
just so you know.
- I wasn't trying to.
- Right.
- But I did realize that
he was in duress in that moment.
I tried to make up for it and I was like,
my sleeve doesn't have any mud on it.
Wipe your eyes on my sleeve, man.
And he was like, nah,
nah, nah, I was like dude.
- Was Blandine okay with this?
Where was she?
- She was trying
to go up the next hill.
- She's like, quit
helping the competition!
- And so he was like nah, man.
I'm like, no, it's perfectly dry.
Just wipe your eyes on my sleeve, man.
And I basically made
him do it and he did it
and then he didn't say anything to me.
He just went up the hill.
And then so I go up the next hill--
- You Linked him.
You totally Linked him.
- I helped him!
- You unintentionally--
- I helped a blind man
on the road.
- You unintentionally insulted him.
That's Link step number one.
- He looked great.
- And then you forced him--
- He couldn't see.
- You forced him into doing something
that he didn't wanna do
which is Link number two.
(chuckling)
And then you told the
story and didn't realize
that (laughs)--
- Well it ain't--
- How he took it.
That's Link number three.
- And then I get up to the
next hill and I realize,
oh I gotta slide down this
third one into more mud
and now there is an
inflatable wall that is--
- Well that sounds fun.
- That is brought down
to the surface of the mud
and they force you to
submerge yourself completely
and go under, so everything
I did to help that guy
was immediately erased by the fact
that we all just have
to go under this thing.
- That's what he should have said.
- And he knew that because
he told me once we got
to the top of the hill, he was like,
this is a lot easier
than it was yesterday.
I was like, you did this yesterday?
He was like yeah.
Like oh so you knew that you
were about to go under all,
go under the mud and
basically me forcing you
to wipe your face on
my shirt was pointless.
- Yeah.
- I didn't say any of that,
I just kinda--
- Thought it.
- Slinked along.
- Yeah.
- But we had to submerge
ourselves completely in the mud
and that was a fun moment.
But then right after that,
we're running to the next obstacle
and it is a, like a 45
degree wooden triangle
that was probably eight feet tall
and it had ropes hanging from it
and it was soaked because
everybody was soaked
and your feet are soaked,
your whole body's soaked
by this point and you
have to grab the rope,
stand on the wood and walk up
this wet inversion obstacle.
And that was--
- Well how did you do it--
- Nearly impossible.
- If you can't have no grip?
- Well you could grip the
rope but then your feet had
to grip but you had to lean
back in order to create more,
what's that called, in statics.
- Friction?
- Well you know, you gotta,
that force back towards,
if you lean back on the rope,
your legs become like a moment arm
and you're sending your force
vector back into the wood.
So that you can get
more traction and walk.
But it was, people were getting halfway up
and then falling flat on their faces
and then sliding back down
into all the people that were waiting.
And I was determined--
- Now if you get up
to a obstacle like this,
is there somebody there
to make sure you go over?
- No, well there's people
like on the sides saying,
hey just go around.
If you can't do an obstacle,
you have to do 30 burpees.
- Oh.
- But you lose a lot
of pride when you gotta do the burpees.
30 burpees is actually not easy.
- Not easy.
- I was determined to
make it up and I noticed
that there was one rope
that had three knots in it
all the way up, some
didn't have any knots.
I'm like I'm going for that one.
I get halfway up and then the
space between the second knot
and the third knot was
farther than I could reach
with my fingertips so
I would grab the rope
and just slide back down
and you feel like everybody's watching,
everybody's waiting for you to get over.
- Right 'cause one rope.
- Well there's,
probably five people could go at a time,
but there's probably 45 people waiting--
- Oh man.
- 'Cause people start backing up.
- Embarrassing.
- I was desperate to get over this thing
and I was holding on the
rope, I was leaning back,
I was like really struggling and I'm like,
I look at a rope over here
and it has a knot on it
and I'm like, belaying
over and putting my foot
on the knot in the other
rope and trying desperately
to push up and there's
a guy right up there
who's helping some people over
but he's not helping me over.
He's just like, and I don't
know if he was waiting for me
to reach out--
- It was 'cause
of the headband.
- Well we all wore headbands.
- Oh.
- They give you a headband
with a number on it.
- Oh it was your number then.
- Yeah that's why I trained
with a headband.
- Do you have athletic glasses?
Like Kurt Rambis?
- I was wearing contacts.
I wasn't wearing Kurt Rambis goggles.
- Missed opportunity.
- I did make it over
but it was harrowing.
And then I hung at the top
and like grabbed Blandine
and pulled her over, it was
like a survival situation,
I felt like, it's like an adult version
of don't step in the lava
kind of a vibe was happening.
There's a lot more obstacles after that
but that was the most
difficult spot for me.
After that, there's some
rings and other monkey bars,
I'm like carrying a lot of weight
in a bucket around a circuit
and all these different things.
There was even a javelin toss.
Like a Spartan, like a, is that
what it's called, a javelin?
Like a stick that--
- Yeah, javelin.
- You could skewer somebody.
- Into what?
- Into a--
- Hay bale?
- Into people who were doing burpees.
- Oh good.
- Yeah it's like
oh you can't throw the javelin,
then you're the target.
- Kill the burpee-ers.
- Like a hay bale.
Turns out we ran the whole
time from obstacle to obstacle.
We didn't do any walking,
some people were doing that.
If you went first thing in the morning,
you were in the elite competition people
who were like doing this time
and that's like American
Ninja Warrior type vibe,
but this was like the
free-for-all, some people walking,
everybody going at their own pace.
So it wasn't the competitive run
to get across the finish line first.
But once it gets to the end
there's like a rope you have
to climb and that's the
first thing I could not do.
I'd never learned the
technique to climb a rope.
Blandine was trying to show me
and she was having a difficult time
so we ended up doing the burpees.
And then I saw--
- How high do you have to go?
- Probably 15 feet.
- That'd be trouble.
- It was intimidating.
And it really, my hands were hurting.
So I was like I'll just do the burpees
and then I saw Christy and the kids
and they saw me cross the finish line.
And we got our pictures
taken, they gave me the medal
and there's people there at
the end who hand you the medal,
put it around your neck.
And so I knew that my family was watching.
I felt like the whole world was watching.
So I decided I'm gonna run up to this guy
who's handing me the medal--
- Uh-oh.
- And I'm going to take
a knee like a knight.
So I went to take a knee.
Nobody else was taking a knee.
I guess the guy hadn't (chuckles)
encountered anyone taking a knee
because as I took the knee,
he tried to put the medal
over where my head used to be and instead,
slapped me square in
the face with my medal.
- That's kinda what you deserve.
- Which is a heavy medal.
This is an impressively
heavy medal and I know
because it hit me square in
the face at the end of my race.
- Wow.
- I'm pretty sure Christy
got this on video.
- I hope she did.
- I haven't watched it back but if it is,
we can cut to it for the video version.
YouTube.com/EarBiscuits, subscribe now.
So that kinda put a damper on my ending,
it's just like wham right in the face.
(Rhett chuckling)
And then we ran,
we got some pictures but then--
- Oh gosh.
- We actually ran,
I was exhausted.
I was absolutely exhausted
but Blandine was like
let's run back and come through
with the rest of our team.
We can support them, we're
all in this together.
I'm like, that's a great
idea but I hate you
for thinking that is what I was thinking.
I don't want to run back, and
then we started running back,
and both of my calves
cramped up, I couldn't move,
I'm like, I gotta, she's running back.
I'm like, I can't do this.
But we did catch up with them
and we brought them back--
- They ended up carrying you. (chuckles)
Over the--
- I recovered but
we got to the rope climb at
the end and Blandine wants
to try it again, she's like--
- I like Blandine's attitude.
- Got this inner competition.
And of course my family's
still there watching
and then everybody's like, try
it again, do the rope climb--
- Oh gosh.
- I'm like I don't wanna
do this again.
I didn't do it the first
time, and so, I had watched,
and I just, the technique
is you're supposed
to climb a rope with your legs,
not your arms.
- Not your arms, yeah.
- And I started doing it,
like I hooked my feet together
and then I pushed up and
then I reached my hands up
and I grabbed again.
Actually yeah, I pushed
up with my legs and then,
I did it a second time and then
all of a sudden, I realize,
people were cheering and
I did it a third time
and then I did it a fourth
time and then I looked up
and there's the bell.
- You got it!
- And I'm ringing
the freakin' bell, I climbed
the freakin' rope, man!
Right?
- That's awesome.
- (laughs) I'm forcing
Rhett to say that's awesome.
But it was unexpectedly
awesome to actually hit
that bell like when I got
down, my family was cheering
for me and then we crossed the finish line
and we all took the pictures
and then it was over and then we went to,
there's this--
- Ruby Tuesday's.
- Well we were so dirty,
like coated head to foot
and they had rigged up
all these garden hoses,
I'm talking like probably 35 garden hoses
under this cement slab
and so I go under there
and we're all hosing off so then we can go
into this changing place
and change and I look down
and somebody had left two
hotel-size shampoo bottles--
- Hmm.
- In front of me,
and there's like probably 50
people at different stages
of hosing themselves off,
men, women, children.
It was like post-apocalyptic except for me
because I was lathered from head to toe
in every frickin' bit of that shampoo
that nobody else had so I
realized everybody was looking
at me and laughing 'cause I was like,
I was sudsed up like a
dude taking a bubble bath.
- They didn't wanna use it?
- I offered it to the
people that I knew and like,
Chad took a little bit and
shampooed his hair a little bit,
I'm like, man, I've never been,
I can't ever remember being this dirty.
It was like the ram in the thicket.
God gave me shampoo
and I tried to share it but no
one wanted to go full lather.
Except me.
- They were like,
I'll do a thorough shower when I get home.
- Right, I was like
putting it down my pants
and then I changed and we--
- Wow.
- Went back to my family
and ate some beef jerky
and some bananas and headed out of there.
But the thing that happened
that I didn't anticipate was,
and it started at the rope
climb and then it continued
way into the evening and it was this.
I felt good.
(Rhett chuckles)
I was proud of what I had done
and I know that sounds kinda cheesy
and a little weird to say but
the thing that I realized was
I in no way anticipated
actually feeling that, honestly.
I thought I'm gonna sign
up for this thing, yeah,
it's gonna be difficult.
I'm not surprised that I'm
nervous about doing it.
I'm gonna push myself physically
and I'm gonna have a physical experience
of completing something, as
long as I don't get hurt,
this is a success.
But I honestly, it didn't cross my mind
that there would be an emotional component
to completing a race like this.
You know, people talk
about completing marathons
and I totally get if you run 26 miles
and you cross a finish line, I totally get
that you might be in tears of joy.
- Of course.
- But I did not anticipate
with doing a little three mile,
5K, jumping over some ropes
and oh, this is no big deal
that it would actually have
an impact on my self-esteem.
It was surprising to me.
And it was kinda awesome and I--
- Does this mean you're
like a Spartan guy now?
- I'm a Spartan junkie now.
No, I've talked to people
after and they're like,
did you get the bug?
And I actually know what
they're talking about
'cause there's this thrill
of achieving something.
I'm not competitive at all so any
of my many soccer exploits,
I don't know that I, or any type of sport,
physical competition type thing,
I don't think I've ever
experienced actual joy in doing it.
- Hmm.
- Because I was like,
what am I feeling right now?
This is so weird.
What is the feeling that I have
that my family just
watched me climb a rope?
I mean it's kinda silly.
I'm a 40 year old guy ringing a cowbell
at the top of the rope
and the answer was pride.
You know, I was proud.
I was proud.
And it was like, it was
so weird to then realize
that it was the first
time that it happened
so now I gotta get my other three.
That night, it was like late that night
'cause I went into the kitchen
to get a pseudo midnight snack.
'Cause I had earned it, I mean,
let's be real.
- Yeah, right.
- My watch told me I had
burned 1100 calories.
Took me an hour and a
half to finish the race,
that's how long it took.
I was absolutely exhausted.
- And is it the same, 'cause
you were telling me that
your portion wasn't competitive
so people weren't like
going for time.
- Nobody was shoving.
- But the people before that
in the morning are in the same obstacles?
- Yes, same obstacles.
- Give me the--
- I think the record--
- The best time.
- 30 minutes, I think.
Something around there.
- Yeah.
- That's pretty crazy.
I mean, for me to be running
the whole time, jogging,
if I'm not doing an
obstacles, and only waiting
at a couple of 'em, it
was an hour and a half
and I felt really good about that,
if I haven't established that already.
So that night, lo and behold
Lily comes in the kitchen.
I guess she earned a midnight snack too
and I'm like, hey Lily.
What did you think about my race today?
She's like, well you know...
After the rope climb, which
the first time I didn't do it,
she was like you go up to
the rings and you know how
you gotta stand there
for a second, it's like,
I kinda looked at your
face and I could tell
that you were afraid.
(both laugh)
And I'm like, I look at Lily, I'm--
- I can see the fear in your eyes.
- And I told Lily, I was like, I was.
And she was like, and
then you started doing it
and you grabbed one
ring and then you swung
to the next ring and I could
tell you kinda got the hang
of it and then you felt better about it.
And I was like, I did.
And then after you did,
and I was like, did
you see me do the rope?
And she was like, yeah yeah
yeah, when you went back
and did the rope, that was
cool, and then there was a pause
and she was like,
I can tell you're pretty
proud of yourself.
(Rhett laughs)
And I'm like--
- You think?
(both laughing)
- And I'm like, I am.
I am, and I was...
It's the stuff that I've already said
but it's also this thing of being,
don't you feel like we
were taught a little bit
that like, being proud of yourself
for doing something is not,
it's not a pure thing to feel.
- Not in the McLaughlin
household. (chuckles)
- You think?
Okay then maybe it's just
me then that I feel like
if you're gonna be proud
of something you did,
it's like, yeah I'm proud of that.
There's a tinge of--
- Well no I mean--
- But you don't wanna flaunt it.
You don't wanna be honest
and be like yeah tell me--
- Being proud of yourself
and being prideful--
- I understand there's
two different things
but I guess it bled in my psyche.
- Well yeah, yeah yeah.
- So I think I will do it again.
I encourage you to give it a shot.
- Well I was reading that book.
There's a book about The Iceman Wim Hof--
- Mm-hmm.
- And the guy who wrote
the book is talking about...
I read this like a year and a half ago
and he's talking about Spartan Races.
I need to, I should really
do something like that,
but they don't do that at my gym,
so I didn't look at it, 'cause you gotta,
I wasn't gonna
go there by myself.
- Yeah you gotta have a squad.
I don't think you can
be in my squad because--
- Oh I'm gonna get another
squad and beat your squad.
- Yeah let's do that.
- Yeah, I'm gonna take the--
- You're gonna try to recruit Blandine--
- You and Blandine.
- To your side.
- No, I'd definitely do it.
I am legitimately, now, you know me,
I am incredibly competitive.
Like competitive sports
were a huge part of my life
growing up and so I think
I definitely approach it
very differently because I'd never,
I didn't think about sports and
competition in the way that,
I just saw something and it was like,
I am going to win at
that and I was just like,
I put everything into how am I gonna win,
so it was a different kind of approach.
- But does that mean, can you quantify,
can you pinpoint what's
your greatest physical feat?
'Cause I guess I'm
saying, I mean definitely
in recent history, this
Spartan Race was that for me,
like a personal physical milestone.
Last time I ran 5K was when
I was on the soccer team,
like we had to run a lot in high school,
I'm talking that many years ago,
20 some plus years ago
was the last time I ran
anywhere near that.
- Okay so speaking of 5K, so,
I probably have told
this story maybe way back
on the RhettandLinKast or something but
my basketball coach was
the cross-country coach.
Coach Gage.
- Mm-hmm.
- And still the basketball
coach at Harnett Central.
I don't know if he's
still doing cross-country,
but anyway, so he kinda got all the guys
on the basketball team
to run cross-country
and I was an athlete so I was like okay,
I'll do this.
I had never really done
long-distance running
but I was like okay, I
mean people can do it
so I will be one of the
people who can do it.
It's the way I've always,
if somebody can do it,
okay I can do it.
- And the course is usually 5K right?
- It's a 5K, it's the one that
went around the tobacco field
and down the dirt road
next to school and stuff
and so they were like, okay well, day one,
you guys are all just gonna run this 5K
and we're gonna see where you're at.
- Yeah, baseline.
- And because that was a competition
amongst just the people,
someone who you're now
half related to, Brian.
Lewis's nephew I guess.
- Oh yeah, yeah, okay, yeah,
I know who you're talking about.
- Was out there, he's
another tall guy like me.
And so we start running
and I'm like, didn't
expect him to be good.
Now he's tall like me but I just,
he hadn't played any other
sports that I knew of.
- Right.
- And I'm like well
he's not gonna beat me.
- Oh.
- No preparation for this.
- I don't remember this
story, by the way, so--
- So I just, well I
gotta keep up with him.
I'm like good lord, this guy is flying.
- He was Blandining you.
- And I'm like out of shape.
Basketball season was
over and I guess I was
in pretty good shape for
basketball season, whatever,
but you know, not this kind of shape.
- He was your height.
- Yeah he was, so I'm
just running like crazy
and of course,
the way that the course...
I kept up with him the whole time
and the way that the course
ends is it goes around one lap
of the track, you come
in and go around one,
and I was like, he's not beating me.
- Ha.
This is day one.
- Day one, I ran.
- Did you talk to him?
- No, I ran--
- You were just running
beside him.
- I ran beside him and then--
- And didn't say a word?
- In the last like
10 steps, overtook him and beat him.
- Were you sprinting at the end?
- I ran the 5K in 18 minutes.
(Link chuckles)
- That's pretty good.
- 18 minutes.
- Just to beat Brian.
- And which incidentally
is not even that good
of a time in cross-country
once you start competing,
but it was by far the best time I ever ran
because I was like, I beat Brian
and that's really all I wanted to prove
and then the rest of the
time, during the meets,
we would actually run
and then we would get
around the corner and then we
would stop running and walk.
- Break out potato chips or something?
- And then I would, we would get back into
where the parents were watching.
I had kinda just jogged along not too hard
but I got to that place
where everybody was watching
and I started sprinting and
I would pass like 17 people
at the very end and
come in and finish like
in the middle of the pack.
Just so I could come in like
chariots of fire, just flying,
like how does this tall
guy have so much energy?
- You say chariots of
fire but I always picture
that guy in slow motion.
- Yeah but I do look very slow
because of my limb length.
(Link laughs)
But beating Brian that first day--
- In practice.
- In practice,
that may be one of my
greatest physical feats.
- You just wanted to
let him know you could.
- Yeah 'cause I was thinking about this--
- Because I once did.
- I was thinking about this--
- That's your greatest physical feat,
like that's the one you're thinking about.
- Well I've had a lot of success in sports
but I don't think of those
as like a physical feat.
- Yeah, it's not.
- You know what I'm saying.
Just like a pure physical exertion.
- Like pushing your body to the limit.
Have you ever been,
have you ever worked out
at a gym to the point
where you just vomited
on your own feet?
- No.
I was thinking about
this and first of all,
it takes a lot for me to actually vomit.
There's the McLaughlin
streak that me and my brother
and my dad had for like, it
was like 40 years combined,
nobody had vomited and
then within one year,
we all three vomited.
- Oh.
- But anyway.
- I bet that was quite a gusher.
- But I never worked out
so hard that I threw up.
I worked out hard but--
- Oh I came, when I first started going
to the gym, I came close.
- 'Cause I used to go to
the same gym that you do--
- They gave me a packet
like sugar water to drink.
Had my head between my knees.
- Well and it's like the
circuit training kinda thing
and we wore the heart
rate monitors and stuff
and trying to burn a certain
number of calories or whatever.
I mean basically it's like,
a couple weeks ago,
I go to a gym but I have a trainer
and we go through a bunch
of different exercises.
It's basically a mix of...
It's all strength
training but it's so quick
and there's a bunch of
it going on together
so you're also getting a cardio workout
at the same time and it
lasts for like an hour,
and I work out, like to the point,
I have so much pride but
the bad kind of pride.
Like I never ever stop
and say I can't do that last five seconds
or something like that.
There's just something in me.
It's the whole Enneagram three thing.
I cannot--
- You can't admit.
- Right, I will not--
- [Link] That you've reached the limit.
If they've told you to do something.
- You have to do this
plank with this weight
on your back for a minute
after you've done this thing,
I'm like, okay if that's
what it is, I'll do it.
So she just pushes me as far as I'll go,
and then I was like sore for like,
that was probably as much
as I've pushed myself
in my 40s definitely.
Which my 40s haven't been very long,
but then there's things like,
I'll have to run across a parking lot
in the rain to get to my car.
It's just like, I got my back issues.
There's four different places
that my back can get hurt
and I've got my knee that's got arthritis
and my elbow and my,
I've got tall guy issues,
so I'm very stiff
and very much thinking,
don't hurt yourself.
Whenever I get going I'm
like don't hurt yourself.
That's the main reason I'd
be scared of the Spartan Race
'cause I was doing like assisted pull-ups
at the gym and my upper back thing snaps.
The rope climb would be a problem.
I think I could get to a place
where I was physically capable of it
if I figured out how to do it
but I think I could
potentially hurt myself but.
- I mean you're talking about
running in the parking lot.
I still have trouble, especially now,
running in the parking
lot because of this medal.
Wearing this everywhere
makes it a lot more difficult
to exert myself.
- Do we need
to install obstacles,
like in the office, in order
for you to get to the bathroom,
I'll get Blandine to come in here and--
- Yeah we can jump over stuff.
- Yeah.
- Sure, yeah.
- I'm very much
attracted to the idea of doing those kinds
of physical challenges.
Not Blandine, I haven't seen Blandine.
Because, well we started
working out basically
as adults at the same time.
I used to, I would play
basketball or do something
and then you kinda just run out of time
for doing that and then
there was like the years
of inactivity where we were
just working really hard
and I did convince us to
get that elliptical machine
that we had in the Lillington basement--
- Yes.
- And we used it
every once in awhile but--
- I never used that once.
- Then we just ended
up putting clothes on.
- We would drink SlimFast.
- But we drank SlimFast--
- But not to lose weight.
- Just because it was efficient--
- Just an efficient mode
of continuing to work
but not have any sustenance.
- In those days we would--
- We would down two SlimFasts
and just keep editing
videos and sometimes you,
one day you showed up with
an elliptical machine,
I was like dude.
Don't, that's just a--
- And I did use it.
- A physical manifestation of my guilt.
- I did use it.
- No you didn't.
- Yeah I did.
More than you did.
- Well yeah,
I never used it.
- Yeah exactly.
- You could use it once and
that statement would be true.
- I used it at least 12 times.
But we would have a SlimFast for lunch
and then sometimes we'd
have a SlimFast for dinner
as well and then we would keep
editing and then we would--
- I think that is the
commercial by the way.
- And then we would sleep at the office
and then we'd wake up and do it again.
When a project was due because
we didn't have any help.
- And this is fresh in my mind because,
I'll turn this into a
Mythical Society plug just
because it's near and dear to my heart.
I was watching, we're releasing
on the Mythical Society,
we're trickling out the
archive of the original
RhettandLinKast show which was a live show
every Thursday night on Ustream.
Now it's just something you can watch
if you're a Mythical Society member.
And so we released the
first few of those and
there's one that features that elliptical.
'Cause I remember you got
it and we did a whole show
about exercise or something
and I'm pretty sure
that you were on the elliptical.
That one hasn't been
released to the Society yet
but just looking at that basement
and seeing how we were
setting up everything,
it just reminded me of that.
Basically just a shameless
Mythical Society plug but--
- No but I definitely have a,
as you start getting
older and you're like,
I gotta do something to counteract
what is happening to my body.
I mean the main thing that's
happening to my body is just
annoying injuries
and you don't even know
what happened, you're like,
I don't remember doing
anything to my shoulder,
I think it's just, it's expired.
- Well my, I was playing
soccer over Thanksgiving
with my nephew Nehemiah and the kids
and I kicked a soccer ball
and I messed up my hip flexor.
- Oh yeah you can't do anything like that.
- I just, I walloped that soccer ball
and I knew something had happened.
And it's still not better.
- You gotta stretch.
- I've been stretching.
- You gotta stretch one minute
for every year that you're old.
So you gotta do, I gotta
do a 41 minute stretch.
- Every morning?
- No before any physical activity.
- Yeah.
- But I do like
a 20 minute stretch,
as my wife calls it now, the stretch
and snuggle time with Barbara.
- Here's my next thing because
the Spartan thing, I do
recommend it, I think it's,
I don't know, there is
a lot of risk for injury
so you gotta be, we need to be careful.
- There's less risk in triathlons though.
- Well somebody--
- That's just endurance.
- Is that where you swim?
- Swim, bike and run.
- Like an Iron Man?
- But you could do
short versions of those.
- The swimming is the problem for me.
I woke up in the middle
of the night thirsty
as all get out last night.
And you know I keep a big thing of water
beside my bed--
- If you swim,
you don't get thirsty--
- I'm a Neal.
- 'Cause you just absorb all the water.
- And I gotta stay hydrated.
No, I start drinking the
water and I'm so thirsty
that I'm like, I didn't take a breath in
before I started drinking the water,
I had exhaled and then I
started drinking the water.
(slurping)
And I was so thirsty that I
was having this inner dialogue
of I need to breathe now,
but I'm gonna get one more
slurp in of this water
and I did that and then I
nearly had a panic attack
that I was gonna drown myself.
I just have this fear of drowning.
- Drowning in your own Thermos.
(Link chuckles)
- I was afraid.
I don't like holding my breath, man,
and that's why I cannot,
if I'm gonna drown
in a water bottle at 3 a.m.,
how am I supposed to get
in the ocean and swim
for a prolonged period?
I cannot do that.
So that's the next thing I'm gonna do.
- Triathlon?
- I'm gonna be a Iron Man.
- If you wanna do
triathlons, I'm totally down
'cause I think it's much less
likely that I get injured
'cause I'm not pulling
on things and crawling,
it's just running, biking, swimming.
And I don't know what the order is.
I think it's biking, swimming, running?
- Biking, swimming, running.
Oh, I'm not ready to do swim training.
But--
- Hey.
Swimming.
- That's something you
do when you're like 80.
- Is--
- You can do that.
- No, swimming is tough.
Okay, so we used to live next to--
- I'm talking about water aerobics.
- The pool--
- I've never done that.
- In Sherman Oaks and I
was like, I'm gonna get up
in the morning and just swim some laps.
I was a good swimmer, I was a
competitive swimmer growing up
and was good, should have stuck with it.
But--
- So that now,
you would be what?
A swimmer?
- So that I would be
Michael Phelps, no.
'Cause I was actually good at it.
I think I was actually
naturally better at it
than other things that I did
but I didn't like the Speedo.
But I love Speedos now,
that's the weird thing.
I'm wearing one right now.
But I was like--
- Not a sponsor.
- I'm gonna go and--
- It's a brand.
- And just swim some laps
and I started out in freestyle,
thinking that, okay, this is the easiest,
this is pretty easy.
A couple of back and
forths and you're like,
whoa, this is not easy, man.
Talk about gettin' your breath right.
You end up having to take
a breath like every time,
'cause I was just a
sprint swimmer so I would
go under, I would dive in and
I wouldn't come up at all.
You know what I'm saying,
I would go, do a turn,
maybe take one breath down and back
in a 50 meter or whatever,
right, but like--
- You do a freestyle but
your face would stay under.
- Yeah, but this was like,
I gotta come up every freaking
time, I'm so out of shape.
I'm in a little bit better shape now
but then I started going
to the breast stroke
and I was--
- Okay breast stroke.
- Like ooh, gotta do breast stroke,
I gotta keep my head
above water the whole time
or I'm gonna die.
- Then after that you were
doing like back stroke.
- Then after that I got out
of the pool and went home
and never did it again.
(Link chuckles)
But it's tough, it's really tough.
- If it was muddy water,
it would probably be fun.
- But with everything like that, you,
like with your running, you
get to a place where it clicks
and you're like, okay, I'm normalized.
'Cause with every physical
activity, you hit that wall,
you get through that wall,
then if you get your breathing
and everything in rhythm and
you're not worrying so much
about competing against somebody else
but competing against yourself,
you can kinda maintain it
for a lot longer than you realize.
I'd love to do that man,
let's be triathlon buddies
and call ourselves the triathlon guys.
Shorten it to tri guys, no, taken.
- Well I already have a workout partner.
- Blandine, well can we be a trio?
- No but--
- The triple tri people.
- You can probably look up Brian.
He's probably still your height.
- Yeah.
- I think he works
in an auction, he works for--
- He's an auctioneer?
- Christie's.
Isn't that the fancy auction place?
- He's like in New York City right now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- New York City.
Brian's in New York City?
- Working for Christie.
- Working for Christie's.
Christie's Auction House.
Candelabras and such.
Okay.
- That might be difficult
being on opposite sides of the country.
- So there it is, my
greatest physical feat
and I have this to show for it,
the thing that slammed me in the face.
(chuckles)
I'm a Spartan.
- I'm envious, man.
- Kiko, I'm gonna give
you all types of pictures.
They were taking pictures during the race
and so I tried to make a point
to make faces.
- Maybe I could be a Spartan photographer.
- Phortographer.
(Rhett chuckles)
- Yeah, that could be my position.
I can get quite an angle
on things with my height.
- Thanks for sharing in
this physical milestone
experience of mine.
I'll show you how to climb a
rope if you ever wanna learn.
I did it once.
And there you have it.
#EarBiscuits, if you got
any questions about like
pushing yourself to the
physical limit, I'm here.
I'm here for you.
Ask away.
- In the meantime--
- Oh we need a recommendation.
- Oh yeah I'm gonna give
a recommendation.
- Don't forget that.
- It's a little bit thematic
with what we've been talking about.
- Recs and effects.
Share it, baby.
- I'm gonna recommend a book
that I finished in two days.
So it's an easy read.
- Is it ours?
- No, I think, I do recommend our book.
I definitely recommend The
Lost Causes of Bleak Creek
but this was actually--
- Is it out yet?
Have you had to--
- Yeah.
- BleakCreek.com is the website
where you can pick that up.
You can pre-order that.
- Nice plug, Rhett.
You just recommended our own book.
- That wasn't my intention.
My intention was to recommend
a book that is kind of,
it's a little bit of an older book,
like 20 years or whatever but--
- Animal Farm?
- I read The Road--
- The Road.
- By Cormac McCarthy.
So I didn't--
- Viggo was in the movie
version of that, right?
- Yeah he was, I didn't realize how much,
Cormac McCarthy, one of
the great American authors
has written a bunch of different stuff.
All the Pretty Horses,
No Country for Old Men,
things that have been
made into epic movies.
But The Road is like, I
mean you can, it's short.
You can read it in a sitting
if you've got enough time.
But it is so just, speaking
of bleak. (chuckles)
It is a just bleak book.
Near future, post-apocalyptic, just gray,
dull landscape, no people and the people
that are around are just garbage.
- You're making it sound great.
- It's exactly the kinda thing
that turns me on. (laughs)
- Okay.
- So if you're like, if
you like a book about--
- If you're aroused by the apocalypse.
- If you're aroused by a
world where there's no hope
like I am, if that just
scratches the right itch for you,
and listen, I know you're out there.
I know a lot of you are out there,
that's why these books are so popular.
Then I highly recommend that.
And I'm gettin' into, now I'm
reading All the Pretty Horses.
I'm gonna go through the whole collection
because--
- Hold on.
You made your recommendation--
- Listen.
- It takes the punch out
of the recommendation
to just slather it out--
- Here's an interesting fact
about Cormac McCarthy and I
didn't realize that this was,
I thought that maybe it
was just a stylistic choice
for this particular book but
he does not use punctuation.
Nearly to the degree of other
people so in other words,
there's no punctuation.
There's no quotation
marks in the entire book.
- Are there periods?
- There are periods but there are--
- Commas?
- Very few commas.
So one of the things that he
did back in the day, he's old,
he's like almost in his 90s at this point
but his story goes that
he was tasked with sort of
cleaning up some writers' work
back when he was a young man
and one of the things he
did is he went through
and he took out a bunch of what he called
unnecessary punctuation
including a bunch of commas
and the guy was like I really like this,
how efficient this is, and
now his writing style is,
he'll just be like,
why don't we go do a Spartan Race period.
Link said, period.
- Oh.
'Cause Link said is just, is a sentence.
- Yeah.
- It can be.
- But usually.
- That is odd.
- It is, at first a little bit like, oh,
am I reading someone's thoughts?
And then you're just
like no, you know what.
Punctuation is unnecessary and then
there's these whole long exchanges
which is like in The Road
it's a father and son talking
to each other and he
doesn't say the son said
or, and first of all, it's
just the boy and the man.
He doesn't give 'em names.
He just completely forgets
saying this person--
- You don't know who's saying what?
- No, you do know.
You do know who's saying
what because of the way
that it's written.
When it's a two person
exchange it's usually just back
and forth but--
- But if you get it off,
then you're backwards.
- But it doesn't happen.
I don't know, it was kind of a trip.
I love discovering something
that's like an American treasure
that a lot of people already know about
and then being like oh.
It's like when you find
a new television show
and you're like there's
seven seasons of this.
- Oh.
- So then I'm like oh.
- Good rec.
- You know, so--
- I'm excited about that.
- All right thanks for
hanging out with us this week.
You know what, next week
we'll be here to speak
at you again so, whether
you're listening only
or watching on our YouTube channel--
- You're special either way.
- There's more where that
came from, #EarBiscuits.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)